now in terms of the police because there
does seem to be an issue here with the
police and the black community this is
from what i've casually observed how
would you
address this issue yeah as uh
as somebody that we make candace owens
president tomorrow
uh what do we do do we demilitarize the
police do we de-incentivize no we don't
well isn't there a way to demilitarize
our kids i'm not saying defund them
but do do we need for the police to be
like stormtroopers running around the
country kicking down doors because
somebody might be smoking a joint
there's got to be a way to reign the
police in
a little bit no let's be clear the
police are not kicking down your door
because you're smoking a joint okay so
that is like that's like that's like
leftism
fantasyland like i just smoking good joy
and the police always just kick down the
door
and because they're just like military
right now like come on that's ridiculous
like
maybe you're a drug dealer and you
happen to be smoking a joint and the
police came at that moment but let's
let's be real about that
secondly i have this crazy i'm trying
i'm trying i've just spoken to joy man i
just came in here
guns are waving um but what i will say
i'm a big believer in teaching your kids
to respect police officers
so somebody can point to me to um the
case this year
where the person who we saw being you
know
aggressively pursued by the police was
listening to the police officers
um instructions then i would say okay
maybe we do have an issue with police
officers
every single case that is brought to the
public forefront the thing that never
gets discussed is
why couldn't this person listen to
police orders and i mean we're not
talking about
like the police snapped on the i'm
talking the police officer is saying 18
20 30 times giving them an instruction
and they don't do it
and they keep coming towards the police
officer a police officer's life needs to
be protected too
and these people are crazy what we saw
in philadelphia with that guy walter
wallace
wielding a knife i mean and and still
black lives matter protested and rioted
and looted
and because he was shot and killed as he
should have been shot and killed because
he tried to kill police officers
um the problem is that we have arrived
suddenly into a society where people do
not believe
that they have to respect adults period
and this is what happens when you have
an entire generation of people who have
grown up
without fathers in the home you know the
idea of listening to any type of
authority feels to them to be
like an assault why should i have to
listen to a police officer why should i
listen to my teacher
why should i listen to my guidance
counselor we have an authority issue
in this country in terms of having basic
respect and it's not a hard request when
a police officer pulls you over
i've been pulled over i listened to his
instructions that's the first thing
right now you have parents teaching
people you don't have to listen to
police officers instructions
if you are black but when we look at
it's going to lead to more black death
when we look at a lot of these videos we
see incidences where police seem to be
using excessive force
right now the most extreme example is
george floyd who lost his life but then
there's
other examples where we look at the
videos and we go
wait a minute what in god's name is
happening
why are the cops doing this why are they
sitting on a guy
why are they cutting off his airway like
can't
shouldn't cops be trained to
basically get someone in cuffs and then
put them in a police car
and not use a lot of these techniques
that they're using whether it's a
chokehold or something where
you can do serious damage to somebody
wouldn't that be good to kind of
do more training i mean more training is
not a bad idea right for the police
saying when is it
when is a cop done a choke hold on
somebody without asking them to first
abide by basic
instructions and let's use george floyd
at his example
because they refused to release the full
tape in its entirety until it leaked to
daily mail
you know some eight months after the
riots had stopped right
he was asked to get in the vehicle he
was already in cops and was asked to get
the vehicle he resisted
getting in the vehicle as he was
standing he was already cupped said he
was claustrophobic and didn't want to
get in the vehicle and asked to be put
on the ground
right this is after he had they had
gotten him from a car so we knew he
wasn't claustrophobic when he was in the
car trying to get rid of his fentanyl
right then they try to put him in the
police cruiser and he starts saying
i can't get in there i'm claustrophobic
saying i can't breathe as he's standing
up
right so once again we have a situation
where we're so keen
to say what police officers could have
done differently what can human beings
you know people that are not police
officers do follow basic instructions
well we got to imagine that the job
they're interested
to put you in a chokehold right but the
job the job of a cop is you're dealing
with people when they're not at their
best right now i have
people that i know that are cops that
tell me our job is we're
if we're at a situation you're already
dealing with somebody that's not at
their best they might be drunk
they might be on drugs they're they're
basically this is not the best moment of
their day
and i just think that it can't be like
hey abide by me or the immediate next
step is chokehold
there does have to be some value in
de-escalation training or we cannot
stand on someone's head i'm sure you
agree with the george floyd you know
that
like what they did to george floyd was
was murder it was crazy i mean i agree
with that and i've said that over and
over again that i didn't have to end
that situation even though i do feel
it's important to point out that george
floyd by his you know um
according to his death record he did not
die from a chokehold he died from a
fentanyl overdose
i'm sure the chocolate didn't help i'm
i'm sure it didn't help but
he he he was not restrained in a way
that stopped his breathing
media misrepresentation that should be
clarified right um but regardless
if i don't think a police officer should
be on anybody's neck for nine for nine
minutes
right um and so i will agree with you on
that assessment but i what i also am
disagreeing with you on
um is the idea that this is the standard
across police officers you know what i
mean i mean millions and millions of
arrests every single year
and we're talking about 20 of them um
that go wrong
all right and nine black men where the
situation went wrong
this year down from what obama was in
office so we're hyper focusing on an
issue
um nine arrests that went wrong in
all of in all of 2019 despite 2020
despite all of these arrests
um and why are we doing that human
beings are not perfectable so you're
never going to be able to beat that
amazing number of nine going wrong
right but and this is the reason why we
know the names of every single black
person
that has ended in an unfortunate
circumstance with police officers
because it doesn't happen often so we're
able to know every single one of their
names
and um you know again i believe in
personal responsibility and
accountability
i think police officers are treated
horribly uh more often than the other
way around
and and the data and statistics back up
my point police officers are killed by
black men
18 and a half times more than black men
are killed by police officers
so you're now you're you're you're
putting the honest on police officers to
be even nicer even though they're 18 and
a half times more likely to end up dead
than the other than the other way around
um no it doesn't it's a dangerous job
it's a dangerous job and it's one of
those jobs where
i think like a nurse like i joke around
about nurses now that are yelling and
screaming on facebook about how tough
their jobs
i get it it's a tough job but when you
were a nurse you also signed up for the
idea that sick people were going to come
into hospitals this is part of what
you signed up for so i just feel like
with cops like they
signed up for a job that was potentially
deadly it was very dangerous
and they are not the ones complaining
and protesting right all right
yeah she's you know but but listen
sometimes they complain when you do
when you ask them uh to you know
potentially
you know you know like take a look at
their
behavior or their culpability i've heard
cops just like
reject it out of hand but i've heard
other really smart people go
that our police go listen there should
be more de-escalation
training right there should be more
training cops should be able to
use other tools other than a physical
hold immediately
or a chokehold or something like that
there should be more psychological
training
that immediately i hate when people say
that because they don't do that
immediately that is not an instinct of a
cop
it has not been the instinct in any of
the police videos we've seen even this
year do assess
it it always escalates that situation
after a
long period of peace again the george
floyd video was not nine minutes
they were dealing with him for almost 30
minutes uh you know trying to get him to
get out of the car
sir can please come out of the car so
you know it's so easy to be perfect in
the retrospect and say here's
18 000 different things you could have
done but when you're dealing with a
violent criminal especially
big violent criminals george floyd was
huge right right who can hurt you the
restart
ray shard um jackson ray chart
rayshard brooks right in atlanta they
were so nice to him
sir can you please get out of the
vehicle you're sleeping at a wendy's
blah blah nice can you turn around we're
just going to cuff you all the stuff
yes you're right about that police
officers oh so let's look back at the
tape though tim and go
well here's how they could have
de-escalated right i mean i did feel
like
that guy was asleep in a wendy's that
guy was asleep in a wendy's
drive-through yeah that guy was asleep
in a wendy's drive-thru and i've been
there
but when you're woken up you just have
to have the cops go
you just have to leave